[Music]
thankfully if you know what it's like to
be targeted and shot by a maniac
attempting to mass murder and our next
guest survived that harrowing ordeal but
endured grueling recovery after being
critically wounded Congressman Steve
Scalise joins us with his unique
perspective on the Florida school
shooting immigration we have a lot to
cover it over here good to see ya great
to be on your show congratulations on
getting it absolutely I can't believe we
missed you at Mardi Gras well so you hit
me with the MIDI right here it still
bruised I know let's talk about what
these kids are going through what the
school is going through the obvious rush
to for gun control your colleagues
pushing that Blumenthal Pelosi Chris
Murphy from my home state of Connecticut
instantly goes to the floor of the
Senate and says this is disgusting
basically pointing the finger at NRA
politicians it's disgraceful any time
there's any kind of tragedy I mean a
shooting a bombing whatever immediately
you've got a group of legislators that
go run out and start calling for gun
control to take away the rights of
law-abiding citizens and they don't even
know the fact of that particular event
and and again look at their bills read
their bills they have nothing to do with
these kind of shootings what I first
think we need to do is pray for the
people that died and there were
unfortunately way too many people who
died but the families too and all of
these kids Laura there were a lot of
kids that witnessed this that are gonna
have this with them the rest of their
lives the prayers helped me tremendously
and unfortunately there's someone the
left that actually mock praying for
people they say oh do gun control no try
it I needed those prayers those prayers
helped me and my family at a really
difficult time and you could feel them
these families need prayer they need
counseling they need help but let's go
find out the root of these problems and
we're already seeing there were so many
things that slipped through the cracks
the telltale signs were there I mean
when every kid in the school says Jesus
I mean this kid was the one that we knew
would be a shooter yeah why didn't
anybody else know about that I mean
these are the problems we need to go
address Bill Clinton today tweeted about
the assault weapons ban said looking in
my eight 10 years I guess 10 years or so
is it salt weapon ban is in place 94 to
2004 he couldn't have gotten that
particular weapon how do you what do you
respond to
you know you go find your law that was
gonna prevent this or the next shooting
and first of all whatever criminal did
these actions violated a whole host of
other laws too so if you think there's
some magic unicorn law that's gonna stop
it from happening just keep in mind he
violated probably dozens of laws already
including murdering people it's against
the law so you know this idea that one
magic law is gonna stop the next one
from happening it's not what you do see
in common number one you see a lot of
mental illness in common but you also
see gun-free zones shooters know that if
you go to a gun-free zone you're the
only one without integrity else has
fortunately with me I had two law
enforcement agents that were with me
that had guns that could counter the
shooter and ultimately that's what took
him down it was other people with guns
that took down this shooter everyday in
America they're people that use guns to
stop crimes to defend their own families
that's what our founding fathers wrote
about by the way they believed in an
innate right of people to have guns for
self-defense and these people that want
to take away your rights guised under
all of these tragedies go pray for the
families care about these families don't
try to promote your agenda in the middle
of a tragedy how are you doing in the
aftermath of those now that you've
gotten through all these surgeries you
still you still have to use those you
know crutches to walk you kept such an
unbelievable attitude I know there were
so many dark days but you kept it was
inspiring I mean it was inspiring to so
many of us I mean we totally were
talking about it earlier but do you have
any like PTSD from what happened to you
do you have flashbacks of that day we
don't and I mean look I've talked
through this with you know with my
security detail with my colleagues that
were out there on the field I mean look
this guy intended and if there weren't
other people with guns to stop the
shooter there would have been 15 members
of Congress executed that day and there
weren't luckily by the grace of God
first of all I mean there were true
miracles that happened on that field I
saw him I experienced some of those and
so I don't focus on the negative I saw
so much good in people
I saw millions of people praying for me
that I never met before yeah I was I was
one of them it was thank you my own
community obviously family friends that
mattered so much but then just the
kindness
strangers and I saw it in so many
different ways I mean you know Bono did
a u2 concert I'm a big u2 fan he prayed
for me before his concert at the
beginning of pastoring he's big gun
control that's all right you know he
prayed and in it and it really did
matter so I mean the power of prayer is
real and look I got to see so much of
the goodness in people and I'm still
working through you know go on a
physical therapy three days a week are
you in pain I don't have constant pain I
you know I have some issues I'm still
working through obviously the nerve
damage especially on my left side where
the bullet entered I'm you know trying
to learn how to walk again without
crutches and I want to go compete from
my job again a second I was a starting
second baseman I was gonna say you know
I played college softball we're getting
out and we're getting out there we're so
80 mile an hour fastball that a major
league ballpark you know I want to get
back out I'm blessed I am blessed by God
to to be able to spend time with my
family to be able to get back to work
again and some really neat things and
let's talk about immigration because the
President had four pillars they seemed
to be represented in the Goodlatte bill
and the House of Representatives which
I've supported from the beginning
800,000 got amnesty not 1.8 this thing
went down in flames in the Senate today
I mean a lot of Republicans voted
against the president's understand idea
of how to move forward which I found to
be stunning well you know and this is
why you take votes you need to see where
people are and and look getting 60 votes
in the Senate is going to be hard for
anything getting 218 in the house is
gonna be hard I'm a co-sponsor the good
let me call a bill this bill really does
solve the problem and by the way we're
working with President Trump and his
whole team you want to talk about border
security build in the wall ending chain
migration ending this crazy lottery you
pick names out of a handshake
immigration to replace you and we solve
the daca program
not with a misty path you get in the
back of the line you'd be like everybody
else and I want to come to this country
this is a great country that people
still want to come to because of the
American dream let's make it about merit
let's get back to rule of law do you
think the Democrats want to give Trump
of a victory on immigration real I think
right there's a war dance earned about
politics but look there's a growing
number of people that want to solve this
problem this Goodlatte McCaul bill
solves the real problem if somebody's
got a better idea bring it but that's a
that's a bill that deserves Mary
I hope you pass it congressman so great
to see you I'm dama we're gonna I'm
gonna have to see you in Mardi Gras next
year next now that I'm gonna walk you
know you're gonna run on the float oh
come on fun how's this in a mass don't
pretend all that great food in the world
oh come on great to see you and you look
great and I'm playing softball with you
all right